hey Eddie hey Conan how you holding up
I'm actually going a little insane you
know me too you know what I really miss
sports I'm having serious sports
withdrawal wait sports are canceled yeah
of course sports are canceled they've
been cancelled for a while now oh I
haven't noticed then I think we know
what time it is Andy let's do it it's
time for Andy Richter sports blast
welcome to Sports blast let's blast some
sports sports hit me this is a super
special edition of Sports blast because
right now there are no sports sports
that means it's time for our sports
glass salute to empty sports venues
salute to empty sports the news the
wimbledon' sports ok arena sports at
place Estadio de mucho Mucho kicking
sports annex Taco Bell frito-lay good
your house of sponsorship Sports Complex
Sports of Wisconsin Palace of grunts for
Dad
Yale University Saddam Hussein
Fieldhouse sport Annie I'm open
ok good throw that means it's time for
sports bless correspondent Conan O'Brien
to give us some classic baseball
highlights
seriously hey classic sports are all the
rage right now so here's a play-by-play
of the last two innings of Game five of
the 2017 World Series watch sports
strikeout sports homerun porch of those
boards bow down board single board sigh
now Sports is sports
Cinco sport and that's the game back to
you Andy you all right
watch and I'll pass it to you
sorry sports thanks going back to you
that means it's time for our sports
blasts NFL draft preview hot picks
preview I predict the bangles will have
the first pick those picks are hot and
now it's time for ref call roundup
that means it's time for ruff call
roundup let's see what calls and reps
are making go that way
sports hooray sports I have a head
sports always sports I'm a tree
sports set to you Conan thanks Andy back
to you thanks going back to you thanks
Andy back to me
thanks Conan well that's all the time we
have tuned in never again for another
episode of Andy Richter sports black
sports Andy Richter's